Okay, we are back
live.
Hi. Done with
meetings at least for now.
ies on anything
else should be
good. Okay, so these are all logging
like basically the same
sweep. Okay, so we've got two
things
weird overall.
You should work with
um multi-GPU,
Um, I'm realizing I don't think this
thing works
on distributed, does it?
Okay. So, it's supposed to just
do backward.
Yeah. So there should not be anything
required to make this
I don't think if there are any other
like obvious common
gotchas. I guess technically I could do
like one of the other M's that I know is
really
easy, right?
I'm going to try a really easy env. See
how that
going on
here scale being
want to authenticate this on the side
real quick and then we will be able
So, uh, there's no team up session here.
What the
dumb. Okay, so this has
run 1.8 billion
steps. Just hard failed.
Maybe I just didn't rebuild since I
pulled the
latest. Could be. That
figure out
DDP first. Okay.
And actually this one is
episode length.
Uh yeah, they shouldn't log from all
ranks. Kind of
weird. Fix that later. We'll start with
this.
Okay, so this is now training at 4
million steps per
second. Uh, the steps counter is still
not correct, it looks like to me.
4 million is not super
impressive. Like we're going to be able
to get neural MMO training at this
speed. Speed is not the problem. The
problem is the dynamic somehow not
converging.
Like somehow the training is different
here than normal cuz this is not
converging.
It's kind of starting to optimize. Yeah,
it's not solving the
end. Be a simpler way of saying
it. I mean, it's it's kind of starting
to do something, but
like not
really. I mean, we have we have things
to test here, though.
There are a lot of possible explanations
for
this all distributed
runs. Okay, it is kind of starting to
train. The question is why is it so much
worse? We have some things we can check.
Now we're going to try running it
through the distributed interface but
with only one uh one
process. So this should be exactly equal
to the original curve. If this is not
equal to the original curve, we will
know immediately that this is something
specifically due to uh with the way that
DDP is working not hypers or anything
else.
If this actually works equal to the
original, then we will know that it is
most likely something with
It is training better than
before, but nowhere near as well as it
should. Also, why is it not
Okay, so this like for whatever reason
did not
log, but
um I mean it also definitely didn't
work. This is something related
to distributed training specifically.
Looks like Hrien might swing
by and building
Late at my place surely will come this
week. It's fine. I got work to do
Let's see if it's glue backend
shenanigans.
Let's not do Neptune for a
bit. Just going to do some basic debug.
I suspect that it's not getting
gradients for
forward. This will be forward
eval. This will be
forward. Ah, that's very different. You
see, it just wasn't training.
fact. So can we get matched matched
results now is the question.
So, we'll do this first. Actually, isn't
the global step like the global step
just
doesn't make sense. We'll do this for
now and see what this outputs
be interesting to see what this thing
does.
So, like this doesn't seem to
be working any better than
before. It's also logging kind of
weird. Like, this should be more steps,
right?
Like we have like all these different
little
graphs. We should figure out why the uh
the x axis is wrong first.
134 mil
steps. Same as before, right?
mil. Okay, so this is actually correct,
right? 80 mil
138 mil. Yeah. So this is
correct. Then
why why are we not logging correctly?
Huh? Ah because it's this needs to be
agent steps.
Uh, are we not getting any logs from
this
thing? We do not appear to be getting
any logs.
Okay. So, this is still not printing
correctly, but I think that's now just a
dashboard error, right?
bit. Uh, it's still not logging
anything, right? Oh, no, it
is. There we
are. So, look at this.
If we do this in relative time, it's
very very similar to
this. If we do it in
out. Now, what we're going to try to do
is match this original curve.
Um, I'll try to match the original
curve.
this. Uh, it's a little awkward because
I only have six
cards, but I think we'll do
like 8192 mini batch or
whatever. And then like num m will just
go
to like
two two
m like this.
Try this just to be sure that it's not
jank out of this.
This doesn't work at
all.
Think was the original was 32 and 16 m,
right?
Well, we didn't mess with the batch
size, so that's going to probably
completely screw it,
right? And one sec, my 10. Let me let me
try one last thing so I keep my train of
thought, and then I will do that.
You can also always do four
cards. The test
Batch size divide by four. Mini batch
divide by
four times divide by four.
Are the ants allowed to die in
this and then they don't come back?
Are we ready to add another full 3D
physics sim? Do you have one?
We're certainly ready to add substantial
hardware to
Puffer. We got tiny boxes here.
And yeah, Kyle does robotics. I've
talked with him. He's cool. Uh yeah,
seeing I don't freaking know what that
guy does.
orenstein,
right? Has a harp seal as his profile
Hello. Yeah. How's it going?
Pretty good. What's going on with the
stream so I don't hear you in several
places? So, um yeah, basically um let me
show you on my screen where I'm at with
this. All right, great. I bet. Very
good. We got tiny boxes. Yeah, I know.
That's that's what you know that's the
real the real interesting thing. No,
Kyle Kyle was asking uh have we added
you know did we add any other full 3D
physics sims to buffer
um 3D physics?
I know we we didn't but no could we?
Yeah, we can you can bind anything to
it, man. It's just that the engines like
you can bind to whatever you want. Like
I'm probably going to do a basic one for
drones relatively soon.
I mean like we're not doing like we're
not making a humanoid sim or anything
like
that cuz like I mean that would actually
be a big like a big thing to
do. Like if I wanted to do better than
Isaac or something, I'd basically that
would be a big
project. Okay, so we've got ants. These
are the trained ants presumably. These
are not the trained ants. These are
scripted ants. So as I when I hold shift
um they are using some helper functions
that I've written in theh file. So this
was like my sanity check of theh file is
uh basically are they actually able to
see things in their vision and are they
able to use the correct angle and
distance to food and to the colony in
order to get food back and forth. And
you can see this is performing pretty
well. There's another guy with an antsim
on uh on YouTube I just saw as well. Um
he's not even doing RL and he's got like
you know all these crazy colony like
behaviors. I think we could definitely
do like this should definitely work and
we should definitely be able to get
something really compelling from this.
Fact like the end I did recently with
all the puffers streaming around is
pretty well. Yeah. It's like we should
totally be able to get stuff like this
to work. Um right. So is this still
agents here. This is still scripted
agents. These are scripted agents. Yes.
When I let go of shift, they start
acting randomly. Okay. Um but when I'm
holding down shift, they're behaving in
a scripted way. And um and that has just
been to test my helper functions. So uh
I've got this get angle function, this
wrap angle function, uh this distance
squared function, and is envision
function that I use in theh file. All of
these appear to work. Otherwise, they
would not be able to bring food to the
colony and back so predictably.
Okay. Wait, does that did you say
compute observations was in there or no?
Yeah. So, compute observations is uh in
here I just uh
it like your script actually reads from
the computed observations or it reads
from game state.
It reads from the computed observations.
So, this is file. Very good job. Is
cool. Yeah. That's that's how you write
a test, right? Like because otherwise
the obs could be wrong, right? Yeah.
Yeah. So in here uh in the actual env
I've got the this is uh why I I need to
actually check that this is right. Um
but I've got the shape here. That's
wrong. Eight is the observation size. So
it is okay. Can they all see Can every
agent see every other agent? Is that the
intent?
They are not able to perceive each
other. No. Okay. So then why is the
observations agents?
Yeah. So the observations are just the
current ant position for 0 and one. Uh
two and three is the ant direction. Uh
this direction is always going to be
because the wrap angle function between
negative pi and pi in radians. Yeah.
Okay. So this just normalizes it to
between 0 and one. Remove remove times
self-num agents or whatever from the uh
Python.
Uh okay. So just eight. That's just
eight brain. Okay. Ran that. Sounds
good. Let's try it.
Cool. So funny. It's so funny to see you
getting 80,000 SPS on a CPU.
That's funny. Is that high or low? To
give you an idea, before Puffer, when
people were training like on GPU and
SP3, like most of research was
proceeding at a tenth of this speed on
GPUs,
right? Now, to be fair, you know, if I
were to run this on on GPU, this would
be like two million steps a second or
whatever, but
Yeah, know this is this is uh the beauty
of Puff Lib, right? I every so often
it's just like ah yes, the high perk is
good. I'm working on distributed
training for us right now.
Cool. Nice. One of the things I notice
is that the user stats of the score take
a really long time to appear. Um, which
is odd because if I run the C simulation
in another, you got the stats working
even when they're behaving
randomly. Uh, yeah, they they do work
like eventually it will actually log a
score. Well, how's the log work in the
Python?
Yeah. So the way that works
is yeah we're using the veclog of the
nths and uh in here we've got this add
log function which gets called and
tracks the score the score is getting
incremented whenever uh the answer how
many actually okay what's the report
interval
report interval
Uh, you mean how often do these logs
get? It's in It's in Python in the uh
arguments the very top. Yeah. Yeah. One.
I changed it to one. Okay.
[Music]
Um, yeah. Then that's definitely got to
be like the ants not
uh not logging super frequently. When do
what does the trigger in C for calling
that log function? It's going to be the
terminal, right?
Yeah, exactly. When the ants die, which
is uh I've set up this condition, the
second one that you wrote, uh Dan, which
is Yeah. Um when the ants have exceeded
their lifetime, which is 100,000 time
steps, they start to randomly die off
with.1% chance.
Oh, interesting. Oh, well then, yeah,
it's not that it takes forever, man.
It's just that your training is super
slow, so it takes a few million steps.
Like, that's a pretty rare condition.
How many are how many Ms are running?
It's not going to actually be as fast as
you might think. All like all the M's
have all of the ants have to exceed
their lifetime. So it's numbum ants
times lifetime
and then you know shortly after that.
I see. So So if you if you want you
could make some live shorter and some
live you know longer if you wanted some
reporting. You could have them start at
different lifetimes. You could have have
them start as old ants.
They had no chance. But, you know, that
that's kind of what I did with Enduro
because there was a weird Yeah, Enduro
is similar. It's just any it's anything
that has like a really obnoxiously long
uh horizon to it you kind of have to
mess with, right? So, you can you can
start training at uh at various points
in their lifetime and then have each
ant's life each ant's reset proceed on
its own. So in individually proceeding
so that they they maintain that uh
offset that you've started them
with. That way you'll have consistent
logging throughout.
Yeah. So they uh have a random lifetime
start between zero and their total
lifetime when they'll start to die off.
Um work. See it. Try try running it. See
if it if it reports the logs faster. I
see logs though. Oh, was that Yeah, it
was midun. It's not a huge deal. Did you
What was there something appreciable you
changed to get them reporting or?
Uh, no. The So, um, it was reporting
before and I have changed a bunch of the
observations. So, like, um, this used to
be 12 different things, right? Yeah. Um,
I've brought it down to eight and I've
commented out the sensing of
pherommones. I really just want them to
be able to go to food and back to the
colony for now and then we can implement
pherommones afterwards. Yeah. Um, so
I've simplified a lot of this and I've
written helper functions for some of it
so that I know that it's doing what I
expect because I can test these helper
functions with the C file. So that was
kind of step one was making sure that
these work. Okay, good. Yeah, that's
good.
Yeah. And then
um that plus um
the um this lifetime condition. I had
this one before and the logs were still
appearing here, but um Okay. It would
take a while, right? Okay. So log so
logs always appeared for you though.
Yeah. Yeah. Logs logs were appearing. Um
yeah, before that it was like just a
problem with Neptune. Um you that might
be what you you were thinking of. I I
felt, you know, I felt like I was
running and I wasn't getting the user
stats appearing for whatever reason, at
least the code that I sent you to. It's
very possible that there's a very small
thing that I did or didn't do and you
just corrected it without even thinking
about it. Possible way.
Yeah. So, just so I get a sense of
shouldn't it be that since we've already
crossed 2.0 0 million steps and the ants
lifetime is um 5,000 time steps that
they should have like died and been born
again many times by now.
Math out number of ants num m is 5,000.
Yeah. Uh the answer is maybe or maybe
not depending on if you yeah just
compute it right and so uh you should be
seeing them if if you're starting them
at the ends of their lives and ad log is
being called quickly then you should see
some
I didn't listen to how many ants you
have. How many ants do we uh how many
ants total are there? Yeah. So right now
there's only one environment and there's
32 ants per colony.
64 total.
Yeah. Well, hold on. Is that the number
of total ants or the number per colony?
Actually, let me in theh
file. I've messed up some of these.
Yeah, it could very easily be that it
takes a few million depending on how you
have it defined.
Yeah, you also don't have enough ants if
you only have like 32 or what. Like the
thing can be training even on CPU can
probably be training at twice that speed
with more agents. There was a I don't
know if this is a a bug or just uh an
oversight on on my part, but there was
an issue when I pumped the pump the ants
uh like over a hundred. I I got a puffer
bear.
Um I don't know if you've tried that,
Matan. Well, he had the wrong obace
wrong before.
Yeah, he he was like he was memory like
you were just arbitrary right into
memory with the obace before.
Yeah. Told told you it wasn't perfect.
Episode length that's 100,000 and1.
Yeah. Bet single observation space is
observation space for a single agent.
Like that was the bug,
right? Yeah. Yeah, that makes sense.
That'll do it. Numb ants here. I would
call it agent observation space, but
like petting zoo defined that name. They
they could have named it better. Well,
it's in the it's in the doc it's in the
documentation now. In your example, you
You do specifically say that. So
yeah. So numbum ants is this property of
the environment which is the total
number of ants. So really this should be
100 given that the number up here is 50
per colony.
So what happens don't match is is one
not getting passed or are they somehow
is it eight colonies because if it's 100
ants per colony times eight col then it
would be like 4 million
where else am I I'm not using max ants
per colony anywhere else actually. So
really it's they should be relying on
num adance. So that shouldn't be causing
if you're just going to if you're just
going to hardcode the number
then yeah other otherwise if you if you
if you are going to pass it from Python
you should.
Yeah it seems like I'm not using this
constant anywhere. Get rid of that
constant then you make it a uh
initialize it in your your antstruct
uh
Yeah, that's your then then uh it'll ask
it's getting initialized in the end and
then um
init it's okay. So you've you've already
got it in there. So that that basically
that concept was just there and doing
nothing. Okay. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. So that shouldn't be causing
an issue. So there's no reason to stop
this this run. And it seems like it's
tracking score right now. Also, we can
see Oh. Oh, we have we have a Neptune
convert or another Neptune user. Joseph
Neptune. Pretty nice. At least until
they decide to move the free tier.
Hopefully not too bad. 4.5 is not not
great though, right? Are they is that
good? Is that a good score?
Uh yeah. So I mean 4.5 is definitely a
huge improvement over the like
0.04 things that I was getting uh before
I made all these changes to the
observation. Go run it like go render
it. What are they doing?
Um can I run it? Can I render it in the
middle of a training run? Once once a
Well, you can wait for a model file is
saved then yes. Yeah, I have to wait.
Yeah, you can in a different window once
you have the first checkpoint or
whatever.
And are you doing the lo local
compilation or you can you can doesn't
really matter how you render it.
Yeah. So this is run 26. So Oh, look at
that. There are some things being saved
in here. Yeah, I've been running some
experiments. There you go. Just grab
grab one. You can grab the latest one
there. You can you can eval
it. It shouldn't be that expensive to
run an eval while training.
[Music]
experiments
model
[Music]
puffer. Did I miss Yeah, I missed that.
uh
underscore
and that's strange size mismatch.
Did you you didn't change the you don't
have a custom network, do you?
No, you're just using the standard
whatever was with ocean preference
policy recurrent. That looks right.
Yeah.
Um,
that's weird. Yeah, I don't know what is
causing that exactly saying.
That should just run. Uh, you didn't you
didn't pass any uh argument on the
command line, did you? That was weird.
Preference load
model CPU. I mean, all that looks fine.
What do you say, Joseph?
Look at his error
model path. This is he just ran an eval
or tried to run an eval of the latest?
Uh, you sure? Get this runtime error.
You sure that's your current run? You
didn't change the OB size or anything,
did you? It looks like this is the
current run actually. Okay, there you
go. Load that current one then. It's
different OB size probably. Usually
that's just the wrong model
00200. All right, here they go. Here
they go. And they're off.
That was not bad. One of them just
brought food back in a reasonable amount
of time. Yeah, I think that might have
been random though. It seems like it
was. Yeah, because now they're passing
by the food sources and they're not
picking them up. It's funny as as
I I'm as I'm running my uh you know, I
spent I spent an evening uh I spent I
spent a night making cool graphics and
such with this. And uh I noticed
sometimes one colony would do pretty
well.
It's just random though. Like uh I think
the red colony was for whatever reason
favored uh due to like placing her or
whatever. Yeah, red red's red's getting
some food. They're not they're not
learning though. Uh yeah. No, they
haven't figured this out. This is this
is just random. They're just going
everywhere, right?
And they
Yeah. So, um, I can confirm that they
can see the food because when I run,
they get relative position to food or
like they run straight to it. Yeah. So,
I'll show you how that works in the
observation.
So, it says um find the closest visible
food, right? Uh I have this function
called is in vision which is basically
just checking if the distance squared
between the ants position and the food
source position is uh less than the
distance squared of the ants range of
sight which I think is 500 right now.
Yeah.
Um,
and so it's basically saying find the
closest food source that is within its
range of vision and uh return its
position in this closest food position
vector. Yeah, but that's it.
Get the angle. Okay, but then
what's wait the closest food position?
How does that get into the ops?
Uh, right here. Oh, okay. It's getting
giving it's giving the angle and the
distance to that uh nearest
food otherwise closest food position
will be zero and then um oh hold on that
could be an issue so I'm guessing
actually this should be normalized in
some way where if it is not in its range
range. If there's no food in its range
of sight, this observation should be
zero or one, right?
Is obs a float?
Um,
obs. No, it's an array. Yeah, I mean,
it's an array of of float 32s. Yeah, set
to like negative one or something maybe.
Yeah. Okay. So, yeah, let me think about
how that works. So vector to the closest
food position is 0
0. Yep.
And okay
if distance
squares. Okay. So at the end of this for
loop
um
if
closest
position equals 0 0
um
then I'll do I'm doing this in Python
syntax
And same with this. Yep.
Otherwise, why is this an
error? How do you do an equivalence
check between 2D vectors?
You check the components.
Okay.
Uh if closest two vectors are you using
rail vectors
uh vector 2D is uh strct that I've been
using. That's fine then. Yeah. If that's
your struck then yeah you just the
components.
Yeah. Okay.
So [ __ ]
Cool. Okay. Yeah. So now if the closest
food position was never found then it
will set these to negative
one. Cool.
Um, all right. What's going on in
graph. Okay, it seems to be going up.
This is the first time I've seen it go
get above five, which is
cool.
Um, what do you guys think? Should we
shut it down and run it
Um I mean, yeah, they're useful, but
like depends what you're trying to do
with them.
Not like this second. It's not It's not
like turning it all up.
Yeah, that that makes sense, I guess.
Um, is there a way for me to interpret
them through this uh through you've got
Yeah, if any of them if any of them
explode, you start asking questions.
You know, your environment should be
like working and and functioning.
Like the thing with RL, right, is that
the policy loss. there's like a
divergence term. It kind of just tells
you how far the policy is off from the
previous policy like KL and stuff.
Doesn't tell you like there's not like a
global
loss. Um
yeah, I see. Ultimately, that's going to
be score. Yeah, exactly.
Got
it. All right. Well, there's some score.
Score high, score low, score three.
Yeah, three is not
bad. Like I said, I was getting way
below one until recently. Whoa, look at
that. Oh, wait. That's agent steps.
Yeah, agent steps will just keep going
up. Ding. If only this was score. That
would be beautiful.
I see Perf down there.
Perf score. Any
difference
yet. I think since I've set the
um number the lifetime to 5,000
uh it'll take at most 5,000 time steps
for all the ants to die. And so it's
going to
take well it took 50 epochs for the
first one to appear. So maybe by the
time we get to 100, we'll see the next.
Now, do your do your environments reset
per ant?
Uh no, the environment doesn't reset
every ant. It resets uh when all the
terminal conditions have been reached, I
think, because because the the way to
get the numbers faster is to have reset
per ant maintaining that offset that you
started at.
Yeah. So when does C reset get called?
When terminal
Okay. Yeah, at the beginning makes
sense. And then when all the terminals
are one, it'll get called. I don't need
to add that anywhere. Yeah. No, you
don't need to add it. It automatically
will get called. Okay. Um, but it's
uh to to do it to do it per agent, you
have to do a little
uh some a little tricky stuff. You have
to you have to make sure that they are
respecting their individual resets. So
you can call a you can manually call a
reset anytime you want. You can manually
call it for a specific agent if you want
to do
that. So you can manually call reset
when that agent's
terminal is reached.
I guess why would we reset it when only
the first ant has died?
Like suppose that ant's going to go on
and and and start training, right? So
you're going to have ants at all all
stages of of play
throughout.
Uh learning will be uh accelerated
should
be it'll be I'm not sure I understand.
Yeah. If you check maybe maybe just look
at enduro this I did this in enduro.
Yeah. So, let's see. That's in Yeah.
Enduro. Yeah. In the enduro.h. Yeah.
Sorry. There's a lot. And I've
Yeah. So, you declare it here, but
you're not calling it in theh anywhere.
um and it's
called and and there I'm tracking the
resets too.
Go go go go go scroll scroll down to
the scroll down to the step to see like
what's
actually there's a whole bunch of logic
right? Yep. So,
um, they get their their their time time
of day and there's their
terminals and then go
down. That's just uh the movement
calculation.
Uh, go down. There's
collision. Keep going. There's don't hit
the edge, don't hit
cars.
Uh, there's reward
stuff. Then we get down
to there's stay within the lines. Keep
going down. That's compute the edges of
the road.
Uh there's
some nuanced
Atari
behavior crashing enemy enemy
cars go zoom. Keep going.
Um there's the crashing logic. Keep
going.
If I build this from the ocean, can I
just play the game? Keep going. Yeah,
you can.
Um, yeah, keep
going. Yes, you can just play it.
And all right, there's a day completed
logic. So, day day completing is uh is
the end basically. So when a day is
completed, that's uh that's a
uh a terminal condition. Um
so uh but but but but it doesn't it
doesn't so it is it only calls terminal
if they've failed. It doesn't call it
won't be a terminal condition if they
have succeeded. However, there's a soft
reset that's called
uh for for resetting the the day itself
because once you pass the requisite
number of cars, you've passed that day
in the in the game and then but you
still have to play for the whole day's
duration. Uh the the reset will
uh basically a reset is a a punishment
for not finishing the the day. So, uh,
those ones that fail get reset while
those ones that did not fail, uh, get
soft reset. So, they they don't they
don't lose,
uh, out on out on continue
reward. So, here's that makes sense.
Here's the day transition that that I'm
handling it. So, this is that right
there is rolling the day
uh rolling the day transition.
Um, scroll down. Player failed to pass
required car. So there's the there's the
reset. Uh, so I set terminals to true
there. But see, it's only it's only if
they meet that that or if they did not
meet the condition that they passed
enough
cars. So there reset round is my my
reset my actual reset function. that
that other reset function is just the
thing that runs once.
Got it. Yeah. So So go look at reset
round then.
Yeah, that's what I am. Sorry. I forward
declared everything. All right. There's
the real the real
reset. So I'm I'm I've I've just defined
my own reset basically.
Yeah. And so this is all this these are
basic basically I'm just everything
that any any uh uh state data that would
currently be
uh present I'm resetting
here. So basically every single variable
uh just about every single
variable and and the
rewards you see uh so see how I'm
tracking the separate v
values just tracking them with m
variables and then uh
um when
they're when logs are ready to be called
then I uh copy them over to
logs. Yep. So there's the RNG state even
preserved. So So yeah. So this
soft this soft resetting
will will allow the environments that
fail to continue to go. Yeah, that makes
sense. So they'll start over. The other
ones will just keep going and they they
will not hit the soft reset.
when they fail they'll hit the soft
reset too and go over. So
yeah, that makes sense. I guess in the
case of the ants, the thing is we now
have it where the lifetime is being
initialized randomly, right? So suppose
the lifetime gets initially randomized
to
4,999.9 then the next time step it dies.
Yeah, it does. And now the whole thing
gets reset, right? And now none of the
other ants got the opportunity or it
just doesn't do anything
possibly. I don't know. Right. Right now
it doesn't do anything, which I think
makes more sense. Well, it might it So
you can call a soft reset for the ones
that
die, have them continue. So, I guess the
soft reset would just be return the ant
to uh the colony and then
um cuz the ants like don't have that
much stuff attached to them. They've got
their lifetime. So, just reset its
lifetime to zero. If it was carrying
food, it's no longer carrying food. And
then randomize its direction and make
its position the calling.
Initialize its lifetime to whatever its
lifetime is going to be. I think if it's
Yeah, that's true. It'll just be dead
again. But yeah, uh no, zero will mean
it'll have a full lifetime ahead of it
if we set the lifime close to 5,000.
Just basically reinitialize reinitialize
the things that make sense to to
reinitialize.
Yeah. Yeah, that makes
sense. Let's look at this graph.
It should be going up. It is. This is
not the worst graph I've seen. I mean, I
I'
I'd expect it to be doing more. That
being said, you could just the way you
have it structured right now could just
be very very slow. And it is actually
looking good. Uh um yeah, the enduro
curve is basically a bunch of stairs.
That's cool.
Yeah, let's hopefully get it there soon.
But what do you think it could be that
is like slowing that down, right? Like I
think the behavior we're trying to get
is relatively simple. We don't even have
the pherommones enabled. It's just go to
the food and pick it up. They can't find
the they don't know the food. They don't
know what they don't know what they're
supposed to be doing or they're not
getting a good reward signal. One of the
two. or they they can't see it. So I
suppose I mean 500 is a pretty big range
of sight. I could increase their range
of sight.
Um and that's the thing like their range
of sight is the same in the scripted
behavior. Do they need range of sight?
Just just tell them where the stuff is.
We could do that. Yeah. Yeah.
Maybe let's do that next. Yeah. Tell
them right where it is. They should they
should go out and get it. uh once one
realizes that it gets a reward. So the
first one that accidentally returns it
will be a that
should should be uh enough signal for
for something to happen with the policy.
uh or you put in rewards
uh that are
uh more more dense so that you're
rewarding behaviors that lead to that
end reward like moving towards the food
for instance
then when they have a sorry could you
say that again about dense reward dense
reward can help you
get get sparse training going
training. That was one of the things I
was thinking about is maybe we should
add to the observation uh or sorry to
the rewards a small reward for being
pointed towards food if you are um yeah
just pointed you can reward them for
moving moving towards the food. Yeah.
Yeah.
Make the reward more dense could
be reward for grabbing the food. The
thing is you shouldn't need to. It's a
really easy problem like the
like if you look at the convert
environment that trains in 30 seconds
like
we're just telling it where the nearest
star is. It needs to figure out which
color star it even wants to get. Um
my guess is how many like how many steps
does it
take to get to the food?
Yeah, it shouldn't take this long, which
is why I was No, actually, how many how
fast do they move? How many steps does
it take to get to the food? Depends on
where the food is relative to the
colony. How long does it take to get
across the screen?
Um, not long. I mean, they're moving at
a rate of uh what's the ant speed? I've
set that as a constant here.
They're moving uh one every
uh step. Uh the total width of the
window is 1280. So it should take them
1280 ticks to cross the whole screen.
Multiply their speed by like five or 10
and then rerun it.
I could try that.
But yeah, I mean when I am running the
uh test version, right, and I have shift
held down, they can see the food in
their range of vision, point themselves
towards it, and point themselves back
with pretty good
consistency.
Right? And I'm using the same helper
functions that I'm using in the
observation. Um, try the speed thing.
Yeah.
Yeah, I'll do that.
Take like a minute.
And yeah, this is about how fast they're
moving around the screen. This ant that
Yeah, but the thing is behind is the one
I'm in control of. Yeah. Like
exploration becomes a hard problem when
it takes them a ton of steps to get
anywhere.
Mhm. But like literally just like
reducing the velocity, it actually makes
the problem fundamentally and
exponentially harder.
Yeah. Yeah. Makes makes if you don't if
like the like you can solve this
immediately with the rewards and stuff,
but like it like you have to actually do
that stuff correctly. So like try this
because like that'll just tell you
whether this was the issue or
Glad I have you guys here on the Discord
to help me with that kind of stuff.
Yeah, I'm going nuts here trying to
figure out what the heck is wrong with
the radian. Sweep still. What? Sweep
sweep still or did you No, I I haven't
fixed that either, but I'm trying to do
distributed data parallel right now. Ah,
that sounds like a headache. Yeah, I'll
be right back. It's best for me to get
clips in back.
that you can you can also you can also
break this problem down into smaller
problems. You don't need look you don't
need to reward you don't need it to be a
full a full circle. They get they go out
they get food they come back. You could
just reward them for getting food and
then that's it.
They just come back food but then the
end. Yeah. It seems like it should be a
solvable problem to get them to come
back as well, right? I completely agree.
It should be should be pretty easy. So
there's pro probably Did you Did you
change the speed? I did. I updated it.
I'm going to let this training run
finish. And yeah, look at how this
crashes at the end. I don't understand
why it keeps doing that. Well, it's it's
not working. It's It's broke. It's like
fundamentally broken. That's why it's
not doing stuff. It should be looking
like an actual curve. Like
it should pick up the policy should pick
up on the signal. Unless you have no
signal. You're giving them rewards,
right? I am. Yeah. I mean, uh, I've got
food, delivery, and death. Oh.
Yeah. Negative one is the death reward,
but that shouldn't impact the score
unless they're all dead. You never know.
Get rid of the negative reward. Just put
that to zero for now. Okay.
And so so they're only getting rewarded
for two things.
So they just wand so they wander they
wander around until they find a food run
into a food which they do run into foods
pretty often.
So then they get the reward. Uh but then
they have to they have to wander around
till they run into the home base again.
Yes.
So otherwise they're they won't get a
second reward. So until they until
sufficient number of
them are that have food are running into
the base as well then they're not going
to be getting that signal. Uh right now
from from watching the evaluation I
don't think that's happening very often.
Right. So you're probably not they're
not getting any reward signal. So what
they're what what what they would be
doing would be wandering around because
that's where they got the
reward, but they're they're not direct,
you know, they're not directed, right?
They're not going to the to a place,
right? Uh do they have homebased obs?
Yeah, they do. So it's in their
observations. Uh they can
see the angle and uh pos relative
position to their colony.
angle colony position
angle and distance I should say.
Are these obs normalized?
They are. So this is always going to be
between zero and one. And so is this
and the the other ones are normalized
too. Everything should be between zero
and one except this I guess is between
negative one and one. closest
food.
Why? Just ne just negative one is
the negative one was uh what Joseph
recommended as the um this is not in the
range of sight but actually we just
removed the range of sight so we can
comment this out as well right now.
Okay. Well, yeah. Just Yeah. I mean,
because that
Yeah. So, that's a default value for,
right? Yeah. You can pick any uh any
default value that's not crazy. Okay.
I I've done, you know, negative 0.5.
Let's try keeping the is in vision in
and just increasing the You could leave
the OBS in even doesn't
really you want you want to make sure
you don't like comment out to full obs
because that'll change the size.
Yeah. No, the size should still be
eight. Here it
is. And that's uh so used here. Put in a
put in a put in a reward for for
um for going towards the
colony with the food for being pointed
towards the colony. a after they've, you
know, after they've got a food, reward
them for moving towards the colony.
Yeah. Okay.
So, let me
see where I'm currently rewarding them.
Yep. If the ant
has Yeah. If ant has no food, that's
fine. If the ant does have food.
Um,
okay.
If get
angle between,
um,
and who's this? Can't you just do
Manhattan distance or something? What's
up? Can't you just use Manhattan
distance or something?
Manhattan distance. Yeah, that's just
like a basic distance calculation. How
far is the ant from from the the colony?
I could I guess I would need the
previous time step to see if it has um
gotten closer than before than it was
before. Whereas if it's we just use
angle, then we know if it's pointed and
it's always going to move forward. So,
we know that it's in the right direction
because they don't have a they don't
have a choice about moving. All right.
Yeah, sounds sounds fine.
Yeah. So if the angle between the ant
and the colony
um is greater than 0.1
uh give them
envctions and
id
um equals
[Music]
action turn. Let me think. Left or right
in
radians. I'm just going to copy this.
Already figured this out.
Yeah, right. I'm using angle diff. If
the angle diff is greater than 0.1, they
turn
right and rewards ID.
plus equals
um
let's do it like this.
I still don't know why this thing is
not like basically I can't get this
thing to
actually use four GPUs on like a quarter
of the mini batch batch and all that to
get the same result as training on one
GPU.
Should we try this?
Uh, what? Yeah. Yeah. Once if you think
you got in there, right? Yeah.
0.1. That's as much as they get for
food, huh? You think that's a little
high?
Half of that, maybe. Uh, they're going
to get that every single step, right?
True. They're going to get it every step
that they're pointed in the right
direction. Okay.
Yeah. 01 or they're going to reward hack
and start anything, right?
Cuz once they have a food, they're going
to
immediately be getting that reward
effectively. Let's try this.
See what happens. So otherwise, yeah,
huge, huge, huge reward. Can derange it,
right? Yeah. Now, let's see what happens
now. Should be like a slam
dunk. Uh, and you you you made them
super fast.
Yeah, they move five times faster now.
See, some pretty insane
uh score, right?
Um, yeah,
hopefully. Let me rebuild the ocean as
well.
You're compiling in between these steps,
right?
Um, should I be compiling before I run
the train? SMH. Yeah, you have to
recompile.
Okay. I've been wasting a lot of time.
Amazing. Okay. Sorry, I'm not paying
super close attention to this. No,
that's all right. I appreciate you
letting me know these things. Well,
yeah, there's a learning curve, right?
Uh, okay.
With - Force.
Uh, yep. We need a we need a a quick
compile command. Uh, it's Oh, uh,
there's something in the C that I need
to fix. Yeah. Num. Let's just make this
that's used in the C. The C is only the
dot slash ants demo, right?
Yeah, that Yeah, what's in the C
actually won't matter at all for
training, right? Yeah. Uh, okay.
So, comp compile it
though. Python setup.py
Pi build
d-force. You want me to paste a command?
Oh, uh, not build ocean. Different
command.
No, build ocean is going to build you a
local eval. Uh, it's you're your build
ocean is just playing the game. you're
you're comp you're compiling that
locally. So all you're doing is running
the code. You're not using any sort of
training framework
uh at all. So you need you need to hook
it into the library. Um yeah, what's the
command?
Python python
setup.py
ext-in place
dash force
We gota we
gota we got to get a a
buffer compiler or
something. But it
uh it just feels a lot like make then.
Yeah, that makes sense. Is it wrong
though?
Like the one good thing about one good
thing about make is you can just do make
and it does a thing.
Yeah, that'd be cool. Just puff up.
Puff up will be the compile command.
Yeah,
it's it's gonna be quicker than than
typing that pops up.
Did you send that in the chat or Oh,
it's in uh voice chat, general chat.
Yeah, here we go.
Yep. Wait, did this just work? I hope it
did, Joseph. I really do. I hate to see
you stuck on things. Wait.
It
actually whole bunch of stuff going on
here. Yeah. Yeah, it's recompiling
everything.
All right, cool. Fortunately, it's
quicker than before with the Syon. So,
this Okay, now I should run the training
script. Now you can train. Oh my god,
dude. It's [ __ ] It was [ __ ]
seeding.
Well, is that is
that like score? Score came up right
away. Something
score is popping up right away now. It
was because everything was the same
seed.
Oh,
okay. Whoa. I see your There's a log
there, too. Interesting.
Yeah, these are when the ants are dying.
Yeah.
Wow. Okay. This is I can't believe I
haven't even been compiling properly
this whole time.
Like you haven't been compiling at all.
Not just improperly.
Yeah. No, not at all. Right. Yeah. Uh is
score out of max one or
uh yeah score should
be like being incremented by one every
time. But I think when it gets printed,
it's doing something else. Saying like
out of all of the ants, that's fine. Per
per per reporting step, you're gonna
have Whoa, it just went to 1.1. So it
was it was over one there. Per reporting
step out of one, you're going to have a
max one. If all of them grabbed a food
and all of them took them back, took it
back presumably if that's what your
score is.
Yeah. So, it's going to increment the
score by one when it delivers food,
which is down here in
step. Check for food delivery score plus
equals one.
Right? And then when add log gets
called, it's here. When should terminate
is true, it adds the log for that
particular ant, but it divides the
score. Well, performance is the division
of the score. The score should just be
it should always be above one. So, this
is confusing actually.
Score should always be above one. See
what what you're seeing are are uh who
zero and now it has dropped to zero.
Interesting. Okay, we're gonna see what
this does.
Um,
yes.
Hopefully, this should be something.
This is only It's only training 700k
steps per second. Slightly annoying.
That's pretty pretty annoying. A measily
700k.
But the thing is I'm using four GPUs and
it trains at 450 with one. Um, so it's
batch sizes and stuff need to be
changed. But at least initially
at least initially this should be I I
thought it was like only getting one
GPU's worth of data and that's kind of
what was happening because of the
seeding. It turns out I see this is
neural MMO. Okay. So this is neural MMO.
Now, we're going to see this whatever
the heck this thing does
um over dinner. Hopefully, like just in
the course of dinner, this should
already train like a little bit. We'll
see if the curve is anything like
reasonable with four GPUs. Shouldn't it
be like at least Yes, it should be
faster. But the thing is like it should
be faster, but like I had to this is an
equivalence run. So, like I had to slice
the mini batch size to be inefficient
for the hardware. So, no worries. We'll
get there. Um, I got to get dinner. So,
uh, let me
see. To folks watching this, thanks for
tuning in. I will be back after dinner,
most likely here, getting DDP working,
getting hyperp sweeps working, all the
things for release. Um, all my stuff's
free and open source at puffer.ai. So,
Want to support the project for free?
Star the repo. You want to get involved
with all this research and all these uh
environment dev and experiment side
stuff. Join the Discord. Also follow me
on X for more than